- My heart is racing.
- They're really, really,
gross, really revolting.
- They'll kill you with one bite.
- I hate spiders, like with a passion.
(rock music)
- Hi, I'm Diana Terranova and
I'm a live insect handler.
Today we're going to be helping people
get over their fear of spiders.
- This is real, my hand
is shaking for real.
- When we're handling the
spiders what we want to do
is we want to be as quiet as possible.
- Oh god that's not small at all!
- Now actually this is a juvenile so...
Did you just cross yourself?
- (laughs) yeah.
- [Woman] Look at its legs
they move all at the same time!
Why?
- Oh, they are soft.
- [Diana] It's soft right?
(screaming)
- Do they smell fear?
Does he know that I am afraid?
- You're doing great, hey you did this.
This one right here is a
chilean red flame dwarf.
They're a tiny spider but
they're actually full grown.
- Oh my god!
- Oh no! (laughing)
- Why would you torture is like that?
- They actually love to
be in small dark places.
- Okay.
- Why? Get him...
Oh, I don't like it!
- Will this kill me if it bites me?
- Maybe it will take you to the E.R.
Now you might want to get
yourself a multipoo doggy,
a little hybrid, but
nature has created its own
hybrid arachnid in the whip scorpion.
- (gasps) Oh!
- It's like a cricket and a cockroach
and a scorpion with that tail.
It almost looks like a shrimp.
- This is what Will Smith
killed in Men In Black!
- I'm starting to get a
little bit more relaxed.
- It's like a bunch of twigs on my hand.
- I just was worried you
didn't get it close enough.
- Yeah, no I did.
- It's still weird
looking and it feels weird
and if I saw this I'd still
kind of want to kill it.
I'm so sorry.
- Oh my gosh, everybody
should have one of these
they're the perfect present for Christmas,
for Valentines Day, you name it.
It's a rose hair tarantula.
- That is not a spider, that is a rodent.
- She needs you she needs you.
- Does she?
- Don't you think it's like
a new jewelry statement?
- No.
- Now put your other hand again.
- (squeals)
I'm just holding a spider by myself.
- She trying to get in my mouth?
Do they all hang out in your mouth?
- Say bye!
Kiss her leg.
- I've held a snake,
I've jumped off cliffs,
and this is still one
of the scariest things
I've done in my entire life.
- As like a species, I like
you, I appreciate you guys,
I like you from a distance.
Like I like my ex
boyfriends from a distance.
- I'm definitely less
scared of big spiders.
I still don't really like
small spiders I guess.
- Am I still going to run away from them?
Yes.
But will I be able to not scream as loud?
Maybe.
(rock music)